[Music]
you
we uh we love what say make sure
everybody got me
[Music]
barely
[Music]
yo boy
you're still stitch my Santa Frank I
guess allocate that was going on he was
going on it's kind of like a family you
look at the number of things we were all
the skills we don't want to start it
we're starting to hear early stages
about the golden ones and music I don't
know a bit keep anyway solo but I never
heard the phrase that would it not the
next direct next season member Gary it
was kind of chaotic a lot of uncertainty
we had to rise to this challenge and to
go from the studio while working in
person day-to-day to working distributed
all over the future January 22 seconds
we developed a five phase plan driven by
five priorities in the top priority for
us was employee sailor man was so hard
to get her in the closet is working and
also ensuring that
now in order to do that we had to look
at provisioning designers engineers
testers there's so many I always tell
people video agumon way up is between 70
and her toys and in March it was four
candidates the atif was incredible
through this I mean it was one of those
moments where behind the scenes David I
know I know use master something with me
all the costings know those are
expensive
ya know he said $500 almost went in
really busy and we wanted to make sure
that our families especially the most
vulnerable families in our community
would be able to be taken care of in
that time so we asked what can we give
her kids in the area so we we actually
partnered with Boys and Girls Club in
the area to help provide food for kids
who were no longer going to school they
are serving about 500 meals per day and
at this point a lot to everything but to
me is how much we're all driven by that
mission I think what
you wanna top-down view I got you
there's you good this time I thought it
started in London I mean I want the deal
[Music]
via DLC starts at one all right this
will be your wait until you see what we
gonna show you next I'll take the city
stitch it is bag today you know would be
nice - ain't no switch not that he's not
wrong either narrow
[Music]
I'm what Dom supposed to pull up me yeah
I'm in here bro you can't there you go
yeah I was like I was just trying to see
it was like oh yeah we have to start
over on that game because we minutes
your attic completely certain people
we're too drunk attack it's gonna take a
minute for that trucker at 50 get here
paddock was in the bushes job then we
did wake them up but I was up I just
didn't know it was already on here we go
it's a job expectations low for next
season let's see just trying to play I'm
going here back to everything let's go
we got a deal okay 8 minutes and 45
seconds goes to be honest I thought this
was going to happen well at are you not
too late you made you made it you made
it when 8 minutes to spare sir
Oh solve what's going on Rafaela super
chat I don't know if y'all know that but
I don't give a damn about this starve
you so messy here you go super chat
therefore where I know you ain't working
your blaze if you want to hear talking
to a debit card can you put back his
cash
yeah any anybody gonna treat this like
what a business is right now
oh it's not Forte's businesses its
GameStop's business out why what what
you talking about
we to the world bottles of milk
Oh cash back though
Saudi is God I hope is great it is a god
yes it is a citizen it I sent you that
blaze we sent you a link bro it's on
discord I like go decide they got stuff
up there yes what's up this is cool to
the game world crashes why mean the the
the CEO got [ __ ] up for this call so
yeah he did yeah yeah he said he got
tear gas and everything else but there's
not a lot of other CEOs and a stepping
up like that that's what I'm saying he
or the front lines him damaged he called
out Phil Spencer to wait what
he said like feels like basically was
asking Phil Spencer and I think somebody
else he was saying like put your money
where your mouth those like all really
like it's time to time for like every
CEO to step up and like use your
platform and yeah it was like in his uh
that little thread about the about that
what happened he like a couple tweets
down said something about he like tagged
Phil Spencer in there
so wicked what did we expected what's
your expectations witness I mean I kind
of wanted some story stuff to but I you
know I know that we're probably gonna
get more of the best thing that was to
take them King right now he wasn't thank
you that's right there with you let's go
after the past two seasons we [ __ ]
deserve
well I'll put it this way if they if
they fail on season 11 they will have to
make it a king is still buying it so you
regardless I don't know we took quite a
bit we ain't left but then they brought
it back with taking Kings so this is the
time Alexander Louie what's going on
Smitty Smith what's going no y'all not
this it's not about disrespecting what
Bungie doing we actually understand
what's going on it's not that type of
party trust me well what's wrong
no not done with this like you know why
you're not respecting that we literally
was just talking about that yeah it's
not like they say oh you're gonna just
do a eight minutes Moses Ark silence we
definitely respect him what's going on
we actually said it's a cool moon we're
talking about CEO when he's their own
Pete Parsons is actually on the front
lines right now
so yeah respect continue what you're
saying if they need to take a penguin
egg to rejuvenate the fanbase yeah but
we've got to be that we got to be
realistic with what they're gonna be
presented before the $10 season amount
of active DLC they're gonna show oh you
don't know for September yeah gotta be
we'll see they for the show yes that has
to be taken King level this will save
the game type of DLC because if to take
a king didn't rub I don't think we would
have had destiny to shard the misogynist
prom I'm so over destiny dusty is just
diet halo halo is where's that a little
better get his story together fellows
that's true
diet halo Wow how could you say that
about the developer that made one of
your favorite franchises ever stay safe
bro stop it they don't have enough to
keep the momentum so these fields will
feed us but usually that meal is
September be lit no front yeah you get
everything in September you get the
mashed potatoes you
desert yeah so we just got the orders
right now but in peach cobbler week we
get we get steak and in September
they'll scrub nurse file a super chat
bout to pull the trigger on this game
destiny won't turn me away guess I'm
about to lose many hours of my life try
to catch up to the pain
look look nourish you you might want to
watch this stream before you pull the
trigger
yeah yeah I would advise let's see what
they're gonna do with it they do two
tokens and a blue we gonna be taking the
most rewarding you public a history
cuz we can make anything entertaining
what if we can make that Sony ps4 tech
hard luck so deal it yeah right right
right oh yeah we fool did you see that
podcast man it's so it's almost a 6,000
no dizzy weed is it available yeah I
just don't I don't want to talk over
anybody you don't tell me did to help me
tell me how forgot huh forgot to leave
is it over there man you know how how's
the mixer life well it's almost threw up
Majewski
that's a whole that's a whole nother
subject that we third place you know
what the FTL is not alliance it is the
truth now I gotta say this business now
look good right now because we changed
every twitch and we got three in here
sound two three that's in there
vixen vixen good Lords with something
Cilicia yeah yeah sleep
Oh Facebook it even shows oh love so
it's youtube today YouTube is sure to
love did you see um the PC gaming shows
the Saturday game yeah I don't know what
to do three streams this week but now we
do it three streams I'm referring I'm
referring to that X column but to get it
now let's see that that's why I'm like
tempted door because I supposedly Atlas
is gonna be there I kind of got a list
persona 5 apiece I need that persona 5
on PC that's good shot the cat he said I
watched you in a box before but never
actual destiny revealed solo yay boxes
doing this thing right now he got his
twitch thing going so long yeah yeah we
go definitely I definitely need to do in
love we've always done them kind of
separate audiences but um yeah that
would be kind of dope this thing kind of
came again and I couldn't tell Wiki
could tame it down oh here comes small
along with the hey yo lucky the cold
water has arrived that's not gonna stop
you for being in the stream watching it
is it let's go a mutant see
let's go by Allah's hand each smoking
jacket
what you mean join the realm like a
membership of the realm already and now
it looks like I'm mark knows really I'm
the destiny to general manager I'm look
smooth on the destiny - game director
before we start the show today we wanted
to just acknowledge the circumstances
and the unprecedented times we're in
this is not how we had planned this
several months ago to talk about the
future of destiny - and reveal where
we're headed with the team you know this
shows not how basements and with our
kids and our dogs and all sorts of stuff
on our laps
well well we're trying to make this game
yet the this is like there's like an
herit weirdness to this even the
weirdness of you know this is the first
time I've seen you in person for in the
last like probably three months and I
know people know but outside of the show
that is work like those aren't actually
pretty close like we hang out we talk
all the time our significant others our
buddies like and so you know this is
it's like it's super weird just to see
you in person not on a screen it's just
totally bizarre yeah this is not how we
envisioned this and certainly our hope
was that it would be more than just us
two talking about this stuff I've got a
$5 super chair from stitch bungee is
here is like delicious mill but this is
all you getting so just go get food out
there is no second
I feel like my stream still a does
anybody else to live Oh watching you
watching on ya YouTube when a refresher
program
okay drift the baby yes I'm good now
it's gonna be another one it's gonna be
shown another person see if it's not
gonna fall the full time somebody's on
the stranger for the thoroughfares
Oh
yeah that was a stranger what a little I
get stranger yeah
Oh
that's the pyramid
oh yeah the stranger with no top that's
weight on the back
oh it's definitely the stranger talk
about finally tied us up I love how
they're showing her coming back question
is did they know that they were meeting
each other yet
all right that's true
Oh things are lining up now okay sniffs
that make sense the fish is what I
thought you hated to see she arranged it
September to all this this is what I
brought you here to see whoa
there was a pyramid ship mm-hmm so it
has it been there already is it finally
time to explain yeah it was a listen
like some jerk said that the strip we
are done with the stranger story and as
you get back into destiny and you keep
like beyond like character who says that
she's not forged in light and where the
two of you meet ground can break becomes
a pretty interesting tool to to leverage
here and that's need to be on light and
going forward you know it is the
beginning of a brand new era in destiny
to this fall you're gonna discover
Europa a brand new destination and one
of the first destinations we envisioned
long ago when destiny began this is the
birthplace of the XO in the sight of a
newly active pyramid ship as a player
you're gonna face aramis a fallen
warrior wielding a brand new power born
from a very ancient darkness like you
Aramis is a leader but unlike you she
seeks revenge against the traveler for
scattering her people's once great
houses to the cosmic winds it's up to
you to confront Aramis and her growing
empire on the frozen battlegrounds of
Europa and it's up to you to go beyond
and discover long dormant secrets hidden
beneath the surface in places lost the
time like the deep snow crypt yes doing
it there's a lot more of it than you
might imagine
and here's your first look a gameplay
stick to take efforts take my money here
you announce the Rays will be in the
crib darkness resides within beckoning
you this is a truth we cannot hide from
and so we must embrace it
[Music]
the line between light and dark is so
very thin let's cross it together
[Music]
they notice that in this gameplay but
yes
relationship has always been abusive
lightships to all currently supported
platforms on September 22nd thank you it
told you yourself a new era in destiny
where players will discover the true
nature of the light and the dark not
just walking the thin line between but
wielding the darkness itself as a weapon
with stasis we did just get like a very
brief look at that today and you know
obviously we're gonna end up showing
more throughout the course of the summer
and the other thing is stasis this new
power isn't just gonna be Guardian
superstand abilities it's a brand new
damage type so that means it's gonna
ultimately sit alongside solar learning
and void as the first new element we've
introduced to the game since the
original deston released way back in
2014 this is a big deal like it's a big
deal to add this to the universe it
changes everything
it's a lot of work yeah you got a
glimpse of this this new power and it's
definitely the pursuit acquisition and
the player's ability to wield it if
somebody's gonna be woven in through the
narrative of the game like the game was
kind of a collision course between you
and and Aramis and we're gonna show you
a bunch more about stasis later in the
year because though we're excited about
what we're delivering this fall we did
say that destiny to be on light was the
beginning of a new era what does that
mean well it means that we're thinking
about destiny beyond just any given year
and thinking about it over time oh and
so we want to take a look into kind of
the long future of destiny but when you
want to look ahead like we're about to
do it all starts back at the beginning
stitch addict are you Loki work of that
bungee he say you look like looks a
little Smith I'm done look man all I'm
saying is you've never seen me in Busan
look Smith in the same travel and yeah
their eluting sure they're not probably
being a dieter eat it's gonna be just
destiny going forward scream shut up is
right this is your battery I'll give it
right do you ain't won you nothing yeah
happy birthdays for you what is what
your arguments bring us down but there
won't be as Justin I'm listening they
all bow before me give your life
we have slain his mood we have measured
we did all this and now the taken King
comes for us all
that was the dough music is so good
[Music]
yeah we thought we were indestructible
whoa
the roots might be the release of my
reach don't be hard a with fall from the
Lord's young wolves howl that's I guess
I that's the only thing serve all is
done that's relevant in this entire game
slow heavy user action shots this is
really what I hate it started hates of
all of it because it forsaken so this is
to be a reckoning HUDs affair god
[Music]
it's right up there it's right up there
taken King they never told you you shot
that dude was too into two bullets two
shots
it seems those responsible for our
collapse are coming it's a good look at
let you know how far below that base fix
the polygon you lil bit of light
do you know which side you're on
the witch queen what thot 20-20-20
if it's the wrong side light fall
working title working title today right
inside of destiny - it starts with B on
light coming this fall it's gonna
continue with the next major expansion -
which Queen and light fall is gonna kind
of drive this all - a - a moment these
three releases represent this new era in
destiny these heirs began really in 2014
with that era of light where you know
players enter destiny for the first time
they were resurrected they went to the
tower they learned about the things the
children were scared of and you know we
we exited that era when we became
guardians we are now coming out of an
era of loss of our powers one of our
mentors are innocents and soon we will
be entering an era of darkness and it's
not clear we are all in on destiny -
last year we laid out a vision for the
game that we wanted to build the
definitive action MMO place it an
awesome time anywhere with your friends
we are still completely committed to
this ambitious vision and we're gonna
continue reaching to deliver it and
destiny - and to be clear as I'm sure
like over here you know some mix of salt
and space dad you know we haven't gotten
everything right out of the game yeah
you know for example we've already been
working on changes that we're gonna make
- our seasonal model in the year for to
get a bunch of the foam out that's in
the game right now
this is a response not only to your
feedback but just so I got a respect
about Luke like he doesn't just PR talk
around stuff working on things like
transmog and that's gonna be on this
team armor is kind of always valuable to
you because it can always represent a
look for you to chase and we've got a
bunch of other improvements to the
experience that we're working on things
like the quest log it's gonna get like
another awesome revision
we've got like small touches like a off
request one and I think when we started
beyond life this was one that I made to
my exact and and you know the getting a
dark title screen back in destiny so
that the light white heat of the title
screen doesn't light up your entire
apartment at 2:00 a.m. so there are the
small features but then there's also
some big features and maybe one the
biggest is next generation support I
think the most examples the game's gonna
run at 60 frames per second yes and the
stream we're good going back to cops
that's it please cease in the bushes
vacation to your next generation console
of choice at no extra charge on
PlayStation oh you'll be able to upgrade
to PlayStation 5 for free and on Xbox we
will support smart delivery whoa
also different and plain English this
means if you own destiny - expansion
comes 399 now or in the future or by
beyond light in September you can keep
playing on the same family console sorry
without buying the expand yes I could be
free of the cheating on Steve yes don't
have to wake up smart delivery babies
work intergenerational cross play all
within each console platform ecosystem
as well yeah this means that if you're
your brother's plan on ps4 and your
sisters play on s5 all three of you can
play together so 30 frames or 60 phrases
way to guess that's gold this let's go
that way
hey I heard that was an advantage next
year week and indeed it is an advantage
just go oh well same ecosystem yes
so shadow keepers cross play and shadow
free from an early generations place
spruce [ __ ] up and that's we got to play
we're not doing that with this falls
destination Europa it's a brand new
place you've never been before and both
the witch queen and light fall you also
include brand new never-before-seen
destination yes new expansions will
stretch out awesome timeline that's
gonna bring much anticipated enemies to
the forefront and hopefully deliver some
twists turns drama that we don't think
anyone's gonna see coming but to deliver
these big content
each and every year and keep building on
top of our seasonal experiences while
making technological leaps forward some
guys we also need to make some big
changes to the way we treat some of our
older legacy content the stuff that
leviathans gone this is a huge game we
have nine destinations 40 story missions
what plan is well I can write 17 strikes
31 PvP members three buddies bushes and
hundreds of game systems that layer on
top of that I could go on and I probably
screwed up one of those numbers the fact
is the game is too large to efficiently
update and maintain we're on track to be
like 115 gigabytes on PlayStation alone
and our updates to the game are huge and
we're starting to reach the limits of
our ability to patch we don't want to
start over from from scratch there it is
you can gloat afterwards and we don't
want people have to start over we don't
want to have that loss of continuity
within our game systems and our
communities and all the players together
we don't want to put another number on
yeah it is over here's our plan
each year just as a new expansion comes
out we're gonna cycle older less
actively played activity and destination
content out of the live game and into
what we're calling the destiny content
of all the dcv
moving content into this vault it's
gonna allow us to add support for D to
four years including beyond like the
witch green and light for this vault
it's also gonna allow us to take content
from destiny one do some work on it get
it ready to come back into the destiny
to ecosystem so we're not just going to
be taking stuff away we're also going to
be going into those classic vaults and
kind of bring some stuff back or
activity yeah the stuff from B Warner
thinking about the greatest hits of
Destiny like voids got new tracks we can
lay down and background music is that
look like yeah there's a lot of stuff
that people there's a lot of awesome
stuff that the team is built over them
you know six years of six years of
making destiny and that destiny two
players totally have missed out on like
later this year
doesn't wants cosmodromes coming back
this fall it's a selectable destination
oh if three strikes are also gonna come
back during season 12 in season three
and one of the awesome thing here is a
bunch of players haven't played seven
septics was epic Z strike from the beta
oh we go in like summer 2014 is they
like the old dislike the demos it the
definitive like original strike that we
felt like hit the right notes yeah in
destiny one right and we left all that
behind when we made destiny too and
we're saying like we don't want to do
that again well let's not do that again
but let's also reach in the past and
like bring it into the present there's a
lot of good you can't resell me that
[ __ ] later I think it'd be pretty
amazing this year to see the vault of
glass kind of fun fall coming in your
board in front of players like I can
imagine things they just fit both the
glass coming back got me to the modern
context yes but still preserving that
like classic feel this fall on the
expansion comes out not only we're gonna
be bringing back cosmodrome and adding
your ropes so we're gonna look at some
of that content that's been in a game
for a long time that's been free and is
a fall aid and that's that's when some
of that is going to be vaulted well
after the show we're gonna have
more in-depth article but you can read
on our plans for for vaulting content on
budget on that put the quest up drug
addition to the run precedent approach
and what it means for the game this year
and for the game going forward we're
also gonna be conducting a bunch of
interviews to answer your big questions
and we will continue the conversation
with coverage in our ongoing I respect
that direction many conversations as
well there will be a bunch of player
support and dps articles I got about 60
frames man I'm cool with the place a
bunch of bets on that destiny cosmic
Lord whether it's the traveler waking up
whether it's the stranger dissolving
after telling you you know there's
there's so much more to explore out
there and so we're gonna start to bring
a bunch of these threads home and here's
a look at the beginning of those threads
coming home to roost
summer sees the marabous sees it of
arrivals yes that's good today
the almighty has been reduced to
smoldering ash
and with Ella is like rasputin's who can
stop us he gasped they poor no cure
Jesus their shadow reaches is their
message a warning a trick
we can't know until we hear their words
for ourselves you bring weapons
you will not need help
that darn trainer we offer like a
feature that looks like a yes the
darkness reached out something here's
the witch sister of the taken King
Sabbath oh well
[Music]
Gunjan
[Music]
public until we get a clean line that
holds the second unless
bleech
[Music]
[Applause]
today we looked at a bunch of stuff we
talked about the destiny content of all
we looked into the past to see kind of
how we got to where we are today we
looked into the far future with the
witch queen look you put getting a
series X confess of a new era in destiny
- and if pre-ordering is kind of your
thing like the PR is gonna go live today
like if your fairies you said there's
some there's some sweet bonuses and you
know that's that's kind of the the
summary of the show where and your if
you're excited about the start of the
online and where we're headed
well the season arrivals we it's kind of
like a pre lude you know it's it's
really setting up that story and so we
encourage you to get in and play there's
one more thing until I forgot so today
like he forgot a brand new dungeon today
is gonna go crazy dungeon that involves
the nine and that's kind of because
there's there's a little bit of business
to get to with it and then but it's got
a brand new set of our it's gonna be in
a really high power level which means
it's like a solid day's work plus a
little bit of skill to summit that
mountain it's free for all players
that's free for all players and we're
gonna show you a trailer in just a
second if you don't want to see anything
from the dungeon just click the little
red X it's the time to say thank you all
for tuning in and giving us your time
today and just for playing destiny and
being part of this amazing community it
has and it will continue to
be a journey let's go on behalf of
everyone at Bungie please please please
stay safe that's their end know we'll
see you soon let's get it you go to
office city so we dealing with a nine
you look like reckoning the dungeons
hold it the armor we going tonight yeah
[Music]
it surprised me I think
[Music]
actually look
[Music]
always like that armor to the trials of
the nine armor
and it's kind of clean trying to prove
first is where yella yella proving the
hundred derogation of rumors
how'd the delegations of Ruth Danza all
the way around
I told you know you was demanding stuff
I said just pump the brakes
I was kid dolly says warlocks approve
are we in there Titans are y'all in
there y'all feeling it
yo Nick Beck said I might stop play then
see smoke this is what y'all alligators
don't know stop with the St Kilda it's
what happens to y'all know they both
times we make more logs action
this coupler said okay I'm in Asia have
a capsule tight the fool reminds me of
so much
hi
you know when's its line at one I'm like
how he says you go so let's say you're
says digs gonna regret that a year look
man he'll regret it a year from now but
that's 365 I can't hate there's no
there's there's there's no fight you
destroy yo slow sit and look fire down
at their two bucks later they better
listen our game still exists six to
eight months later you still bear with
the vision I gotta throw my shots there
I get to talk my tops no I mean doesn't
want to love them
that stasis looks sick they get you know
three years of basically they're saying
hey listen we're committed to not the
number on the box but making sure that
like what is always gonna be someone who
some content there and give the bringing
back the greatest hits
I don't know how this fault situation is
gonna work but you know if all the
Warcraft can figure out how to do
fifteen years of expansion
install that I'm sure lucky configure
let me ask you this though
obviously the biggest announcement its
division who know that's your child
don't you try to not claim that baby so
young should go child you pay pay that
child support that's your baby
anyway oh I was gonna say don't like
what about the whole thing with
officially coming out in front
like feeling about this I know you
called it we felt that was the direction
they build without sufficient like way
where I
[Music]
I don't think
game like this which basically runs sort
of the same interest in gambit of
interest is like a world war that needs
a number at the end of it it just needs
a rotating expansion of stuff yeah yeah
you are getting because you are
essentially getting sequels you're just
getting the sequel that doesn't have
some sort of defining line oh yeah - cuz
they're like we want to abolish the line
you know we want it all I'm completely
okay because they had a real bad habit
of just redoing stuff and giving it to
it's like they're not gonna redo the
Cosmodrome if they're giving us into it
in the year 1 vault but here's the thing
what about let me ask you guys they
stole I guess by digger I was gonna
bring this for your last word up front
is that I feel it probably needed to go
that way and you guys are right
I guess my thing is I work I don't get
enough 60 frames and that's shutting me
up right now right 60 frames you're
gonna get some upgrades for the next-gen
hallway but I guess like okay for three
years down the road for years down a
roll with that same end you know when
other new mmo's who come out looking
real shiny and nice and we still you
know rebuild it in the internet they
everywhere they can probably rebuild the
game in the engine you know Kylie do you
know the thing is the thing we're not
for tonight is porting over their engine
to Unreal Engine 5 so why can't destiny
the thing is a sooner or later you're
gonna get cuz they if you notice they're
starting to use the worst supported
platforms now so sooner or later it's
going to get to the point where it's
only going to support next-gen platforms
and PC that's and I guarantee that's
technically probably when they were
going to do a destiny 3 but they decided
instead of doing an actual sequel for 3
at the end of it they're probably going
to rebuild the game and then like
they're gonna celebrate that year with
that launching right exactly that's what
I yeah and why do they keep destiny like
you know they should have did the same
with destiny 1 was
that engine was so extremely hard to
like they said it took forever to add
content it so forever to just you know
and I think that that engine was flawed
because of last gen they were running
[ __ ] on ps3 and I just you know and I
the biggest thing read is I don't think
they do it but what I don't even care
about this expansion that I want the
whiskey yeah I was like oh man
so Sabbath dawns after the darkness so
to speak no I don't think the darkness
isn't going anywhere anytime soon
but is the expansion after the door and
then what was the what was the name of
the one half the Sabbath those we know
which queen is sounded like my fault
light for my right wait dizzy yeah I
guess I might call mmm what was go off
Rick I love we're getting to do so class
so to speak faces like that sounds fire
we use it a dog the line between which
side you on right so what I assumed
we're going to be you know we're doing
we breaks the darkness cuz you like you
think the reason we haven't seen Ultron
is because he already has that class
just gonna say it yeah but he's reborn
as a as a guardian from from the
traveler like the vibe I'm getting is
this stasis is something that's going to
be presented or offer to us almost like
the end of the gauntlet salvation rain
where yeah they're not really trying to
fight with us necessarily it's like pick
us says we aren't your enemy right no
Fred it's either so it's what's really
going on here no no
from a stitch
yo cog that joint was lit like a
Nintendo switchboard but I'm still going
to get it I am putting myself in the
book thank you for that sir they give it
good though would you say yeah no I was
gonna say I mean I
so destiny I've been playing like off
and on for you know a couple years I
haven't been as like rigorous of
consistent of a player but like I have
been playing Wow for like 15 years so I
mean for me I mean just like somebody
else was saying like they rebuilt that
game within the engine and that was just
a part of a major expansion pack so my
bet like is that either the witch queen
or what does it light fall is gonna have
a major overhaul graphically visually
like technically like it's gonna do
those one of those is gonna be the
cutoff point I would my assumption is
that light fall is gonna be the cutoff
point for the previous like generations
I guess that's the question because at
the end of the day they're still
supporting base Xbox woman right yeah
baby and that's what I'm calling it on
I'm playing it on a launch model Xbox
one right I know I know I already got
the ride back from King I mean don't you
love this console shaming stuff yeah
they do 3 X by 3 Xbox simple continue
yeah but um ya know so I mean I like
that they're committing to one game I
mean EverQuest 1 had 26 expansions
EverQuest to had over a dozen expansions
and it's still basically it still people
playing it so I mean it doesn't really
bother me that there's like a number on
the box at all and I'm just glad I'm not
adding to it I'm just glad they're not I
would rather them continue to build off
of this one rather than force people to
pay right I'm number $60 to like you
know yeah I'm worried I would you to I
guess my thing is the limitation at some
point you do hit a wall with the
limitation with the engine and they
already saying that the game's big
they're already saying that they're
gonna have to remove content we're kind
of getting the idea I don't know if you
got caught they talk about almost all
ball go put on Twitter
Bungie guy you got a bunch of got you
guys again check my watch of these
destiny plays relapse knowing they have
to be but I can't do yeah
Oh dead I would have nuts Lobo talked
about he ain't claiming his child he
tried to act like he ain't got a child
in this race we killed this baby it's
over with he has no right to talk about
us this is all right our kid won the
Olympics and your kid didn't even
qualifies but we all got this addiction
problem we recognize it but what is
right is right got time to relax chill
[Music]
again it gotta be a cut-off point right
we're screaming where's the birthday boy
yeah I'm here oh cool so it's got to be
a cut-off point man right you you've got
to not support the base Xbox whether the
base ps4 at so boy is my only concern
because I just I don't want them to be
running with an antiquated engine and
then you know whatever outriders or
whatever the new next I see uh they go
call it destiny killer that's the reason
you know how we're going into the future
they're gonna start taking away stuff
and put it into you know cuz pretty much
that other that thing they are talking
about that vault thing and that the old
concerts going like that's gonna be a
completely other download I can almost
guarantee you that's gonna be a
completely different download and the
resources they take from taking that out
of the game they're gonna put towards
something else but I do have a feeling
you know I don't think it's gonna happen
for a while I think we might actually
get to like 20 22 before they do it yeah
but they're going to switch them over to
entirely to next-gen did you inquire
manwich what's the vibes what's the feel
in all the announcements what got you
pumped what you're not liking what's the
vibes man shoo where do I start
no I mean I do have to agree with the
whole changing on the climate of
thinkers
I mean it's been done before there's
actually some games I know that I you
were telling me I cap for Ultima but I
mean on there they run to clients you
know chances are they're probably not to
be able to do to clients in this kind of
situation so you're right that there has
to be an end point mm-hmm or that just
at what point do you tell them like hey
you better get to steppin or get to buy
it well the point where they had 30
frames are we at 60 right cuz they are
not but when I was a big point of
contention right this day was saying I
mean many people thought it would never
happen because people would thought
cameras won't go force parity go to
cactus HD they just show he just showed
the directory and September is gonna
look like it's gone they show it a new
directory yeah I was gone o-positive
what's our good old mercury the only
thing there is Nexus when I'm gone - oh
the only planets on here's your Priya
whatever that [ __ ] place is called
Nexus ebz cosmodrome in the tower and
the tank ashore in the Dreaming city in
the moon and the tower in the middle
aged they took they took entire planet
like moldable and they love it--and you
know that no love items still be there
because it's a nexus for is the vitamin
oh it's floating over an elven s memory
to ship itself okay I def you've been
the most I would say optimistic coming
in so now that you've gotten all the new
sir
what are we feeling what's the vibes
gave me my sister they gave me the law
the fact the stranger turned up which we
already knows Elsie Frey anyway The
Strangers turned ER is with eros and
also the drift don't see how she's she
initiation she's initiated this whole
thing the meeting right but then again
that came back this brings me back to I
knew she was gonna make an appearance
because when you talk to her in destiny
one when you're fighting the vex she's
talking to someone saying there
takun I reckon she is from she in
destiny once she was from destiny - she
came back in time to tell us about the
darkness hmm I have a feeling this is
the fight she was fighting back then but
that's why she's made to end up with
eros because she beat that is a good
point like this this might not even be
the stranger from destiny one this might
be this be the stranger from her time
and at the end of whatever happens the
darkness she goes back in time to try to
stop what happened that's why she talks
to you directly and says you know
there's stuff out there that you haven't
seen before well she's fine she's not
Guardian but that's make sense because
that's one no this is will Elsie cause
LC created the exo-m's
she she's responsible for all that
stomachs the deep stone crypt be in
there even more you know so Santa's are
that's where the raid will be he said if
they Bungie you understood how to create
a story they let the darkness destroy
these plans to create a narrative reason
for them to be gone but bud you know we
don't know what to say but buddy don't
need to think too hard to please the
thing is slow mo we don't know what they
could have an explanation why this is
going down like Luke Smith is doing an
interview right now on loophole Channel
oh yeah he's doing if you go to on
twitch on dr. Lupo's channel he's doing
a Q&A all right we gotta get ready
the thing is slow modes like we don't
know they're doing that like we know the
dark light we saw in that little thing
the darkness went over a planet and it
just disappeared
one of the ships did in that trailer
it showed one of the darkness ships
going over a planet and it just
disappeared did you guys see that at its
logo rabies or Lupo ha ha ha so I'm just
gonna stay on my main Bobbi bacha still
of I think that's an understatement
I don't want to hear him talkin over
them talking though I don't have time to
explore - I don't have time I don't want
to hear him
I will go I will leave this and go to
ours I did this because I could tell you
guys to be quiet I can't tell a ball to
separate train to be quiet
DRL yo yo yo comes next what broke down
what's going on but yeah we got a do boy
this man er yes there's very top one
there you top I'll talk to you high days
we'll look at slow-mo they taken if they
do what I was saying I'm taking I'm
taking credit okay Pam you know we all
got girlfriends were all wiped up with
destiny he's just mad that he's by
himself stay wrong for that believe he
see at the end of the day man it might
be an abusive relationship you know
there's always good things about Abby's
of release your what that crap I want I
want it good now it is time to get into
the nitty gritty and as you told me
before and I want to make sure that
people understand this none of the
questions that I'm gonna ask you or pre
can from Bungie you didn't give me
anything I even told CJ No thank you I'm
good
because I wanted to do the best that I
could to represent the community and the
position that you all have offered up to
me something and I'm gonna start okay
with talking about in game live events
we saw the destruction the almighty that
was a technical feat for Bungie proving
you can do in game globally sync live
story events very very cool many players
that were frustrated by the duration of
the event and the level of communication
around when viewing said event would be
essential I will Bungie be doing more
sisters live in game events going back
so in what ways are the gr oh you guys
experience so I think
great question the the way I've been
thinking about this event which you know
I think you said really well is
technically and once it kind of hit its
stride I think it's [ __ ] cool too but
the we had these LEGO pieces and I think
the LEGO pieces with things like how do
you how yeah what's the timing of an
event what's the way that that players
come into the world how do they know
when is the best time to be there you
know I think about this in concerts but
if you're there to see if I think that
you know once you learn that and look is
there an opportunity for players to
maybe be a little more hands-on with the
mechanics or the event playing out
because I think a lot of people while
they did go through all I say you've
never seen me and Luke Smith in the same
place in this case go to the Almighty
may be a disabled portion of shield
anything like that where there is an
interactive moment because people often
felt like they just sat there and
watched Rasputin blow a thing up that
they put a lot of work into before that
with no payoff yeah I think there's two
things you're talking about there what's
like the kinetic action game part of
this like how do I get to feel like I'm
I'm more involved actively like on the
controller on the keyboard that's
awesome feedback and we should we should
strive to get there the second thing I
would say is it's also about how can I
very clearly understand the impact of my
or the community's collective actions
across the game and so you know what is
the like other other ideas that you know
we've talked about our you know how
could we have made the woman that worked
feel more present in the solar system at
large that you are they're actually
feeling you know in your director and
your skyboxes every
building up over the course of the
season so that when you see those
missiles dreamers traveling at you know
physic physically real time but maybe
not like action came that you're like
yeah we did that and and so I think
those are both those are both awesome
awesome notes and some pieces of
feedback I think the other thing was
because this was kind of our first it
was it was really just kind of like I
think someone said it really well to get
clarification so they understand my
understanding and correct me if I'm
wrong is that when the next generation
of consoles PlayStation release there
will be cross play within the same name
that yeah ii don't go system select
rocks you know xbox one and you know the
next tier and ps4 those will be able to
interact with each other initially but
not cross-platform between the two
correct yeah intergenerational yes and
then going forward
mark specifically said that the goal is
usually full cross play next year we had
some other technical priorities this
year next year cross play is that and
both last clarification on that and then
oh yeah well you just said play again
that's what they wanted and that's
that's gonna be Xbox Playstation PC
whadya all together oh she just said
yeah all the back talking about public
debut season the worthy on the PBE side
felt like that was a majority of what we
were asked to do it became for a lot of
players relatively oh man miss I mean
doing millions of these things and
that's the only thing you could do at
the time further the story is kind of
frustrating
what is the plan going forward well
seasonal content have
stronger variety of things to do so
we're we're getting the feedback as we
keep going so one of the things that I
associate with player feedback around
season of the worthy is an intentional
decision that that you can that I made
which is we want to refuel aspiration in
the game and for that season because of
the because you could we could only do
you know one really big aspirational
thing we chose to do trials and so PBE
aspirational players were kind of I
think left cold by the lack of something
to something to care about at the top
end we've rectified that for season 11
with the dungeon that comes out today
and so we're making sure that we have
that with respect to like the bounties
and the the amount of bounties players
feel like they have to do this is gonna
be a continued a continued area of
improvement for us like we have stuff
that we are planning for year for that
is going to give players alternate ways
to make bounty like progress on their
season pass like the you know that I
think can lessen the burden of making it
feel like you can you have to the best
way to play the game is to grab the
random bounties so you get the one for
the lost sector and then doesn't sound
like a super fun way to play the game so
we've got we've gotta get better here
you mentioned that season the word they
obviously had trials was the big
aspiration for season rivals you have a
brand new dungeon which begs the
question is there a cadence internally
about PvE versus PvP for new content as
should we expect the back-and-forth each
season is there gonna be or will it be
split between both sides going forward
for each subsequent season
it's not gonna be necessarily go back
and forth - I think that we are we've
talked about wanting to do a refresh -
trials every year and I don't know that
we've said exactly I can't keep it all
straight I don't know if I've said when
we're doing the next one I do know and
feel free to say I think that we check
about we talked about the PD top and
kind of passively
you'll say the the raid that comes out
with beyond light we're also going to
have a raid that returns from the
content vault and so we'll have at least
two raids we will have a testament you
know we've got to figure out what that
aspiration also that vote doesn't come
to next year so what's the Raiders go
found in those coming back from the
cobalt which raids specifically been the
default date look what came first I'm
hoping people are various it was the
first raid everything that's the excuse
me hardcore players of Destiny of which
especially on the streamer side I admit
that and I'm trying to not be content
creator focus trying to look at
everybody there are a lot of hardcore
than on not been creator players as well
they enjoy highly repeatable content to
use Diablo as an example you have an
unending difficulty scale in which you
can continue to get rewards all the way
forever basically
that may not necessarily fit into the
the destiny structure but GM nightfalls
were added as an even harder difficulty
but the roar structure for that was
essentially a title that you only after
went after once which is sure with the
exception of a small period of bud
Ward's there was no there's no reason to
do those over masters was there a plan
to give a longer term care come on and
I've done everything it in a suggestion
thank you to dado for making this video
was that maybe you can have titles that
level up so you've unlocked
you know conquer how many time you maybe
you get the level 2 level 3 level 4
something that'll give people something
to do so you can show that they've
dedicated a whole crapload of time to
something and it doesn't affect the way
that the game is played yeah that's a
great suggestion
I'm pretty sure we're doing something
like this starting soon GZA it might be
starting as early as season 11 like
picking like some stuff moves around
like gilding titles is the thing that we
are I think another thing with an
activity like the GM night falls which I
think have a number of really awesome
properties we're going to be enhancing
their itemization during year four I
think that you know sometimes we're not
totally sure how a thing is gonna go
when you try we do a lot of
experimenting in this game and maybe
maybe sometimes it feels like we do too
much but you know we are thinking about
that Lupul literally run an ads in the
middle of a stream what's up brother
gonna see mods from season of the worthy
comeback in the future or do you plan on
having additional I mean relatively
innovative for destiny mechanics like
that that are that are not just seasonal
are we gonna in in Diablo you have
season gear that gets retired into the
main line do we see something like that
happening with some of the the mods that
people absolutely love I think what we
are the armor monster do right now is
sneak early some really [ __ ] on some
work on destiny and the the the
challenge might be it's a little hard to
to find the fun here till I put it
together and to make a build I think
that I think that we have improvements
that we can make there to make build
crafting a little bit more
understandable and then I think figuring
out how do we how do we keep how do we
take experiments like the cool stuff
from this season season the worthy and
and leverage those awesome things across
the game like that's you know that's we
got to do more than that
like when we find something that super
successful like how can we how can we
double down on it like that's you know
we place bets and when the bets hit the
player base has always had kind of a
complex relationship with paid seasonal
content and destiny the question is it
worth
I see often asked pretty quickly after
the first week or two of you know the
that man this is brand new that rush
wears off should players temper their
expectations when it comes to each new
season should we be focusing more on the
larger expansions as the target for
highly repetitive stuff that's a good
question
I think this is we're still gonna have
to find like we have a we have basically
a battle past that for sure has $10 a
value if you think about if you're like
thinking about value but I think we also
ask players to play the game a lot and
so I think this year you know we we we
over struck the FOMO nerve and that's
you know completely completely on me
that's that's my direction indiscretion
and I think I let you know I let us
astray and we're gonna we're gonna fix
it
the other thing that you're asking
though about content I think we have to
we have to continue to to evolve the way
we're thinking about content like again
this year we had a bunch of really cool
stuff like rescuing saint-14 was a cool
quest line that had a bunch of bunch of
good elements in it but I think that we
we ended up making you know a lot of six
player arenas you do type activities you
know you can you can lay that at my feet
to like I think that we need more you
know diverse offering in our seasons
imagine a season where you have you know
we're not doing this I'm just saying
imagine the season that's all about a
handful of the exotic web so you have a
bunch of cool quest lines that season
and that's the primary thing that you're
doing I think that we've we've got areas
to improve here and we you know we need
to do it we're gonna do it but you can
you know you and the community can
always lay stuff that you're unhappy but
directly on me and you know if it's
awesome the team did a great job and if
it it's not what you wanted to be or
it's not as good you can you can you can
blame you for it
there are a lot of different avenues in
which people express their frustrations
and and joys from destiny you have a
there's a team within Bungie that is
responsible for monitoring all those
things right yep
our community team and we we have a
bunch of serving that's happening kind
of kind of you know I'll say passively
and that it's you know technology that
that's you know surveying surveying
reaction seeing how people talk about
the game and so I said as long as the I
said as long as this man worked for
Bungie I can never truly not have it was
just like you could blame me for
everything go ahead I'll take it with
projecting the roadmap all the way out
to 2022 no does see more and more like
destiny 3 is not going to be a thing is
there ever gonna be a destiny 3 oh good
question
is there a plan to continue to integrate
destiny 1 content back into destiny 2
you just say to bring it back vog
cosmodrome is returning and in addition
to that is it going to be a lot of
people complain and this isn't just a
Bungie this is to a lot a lot of
different games that it's you know reuse
reuse the same content over and over
again a copy-paste that's what I'm going
to here not planning to make one have no
chances to build new things or maybe
it's laziness
what's the can you explain the thought
process behind bringing that stuff in
and if we should expect the d1 content
to as a whole return to d2 so I wouldn't
expect the d1 content to return as a
whole
just give me wrapping the Machine back
sir Kings fall probably never probably
would be when I think about the content
that we've built today I do think
there's a bunch of that is you know has
been lost in the dark corners and time
as we moved and so I think the destiny
content involves an opportunity to you
know selectively pull things out of the
wall
I know I will speak for myself as the
player and team but the idea of a ship
landing like heading toward a strike and
hearing the voiceover as we go to that
Imperial lamb tank outside of would make
me laugh that would bring me some joy
and so I think we have content that can
that can you know touch our players in
that way it's also a balancing act
because you want to keep making new
awesome stuff too and that's not just
limited to our players wanting us to
make awesome stuff it's also about you
know our development team wants to make
new on some stuff and so we've got to
find we've got to find the right line
between you know some of our playlists
feel like Greatest Hits you know and our
world feels new in the future we'll
Bungie have maybe put forth a more
concentrated effort to bring more of the
Lord directly into the game for more
cohesive narrative I was I asked before
stream if anybody knew the name of the
the Scion Flair that was in charge of
trying to crash the almighty into the
tower into earth and pretty much nobody
knew am Tex name unless you read the
lore that's one of those things about
the game where if you're not constantly
staying up-to-date on all the little
pieces and that's an RPG element that
should be respected but having that
stuff put in front of you is very
important is that gonna be something we
should expect in the future or are we
gonna continue to have to even just four
main main plot points to have to go to
the grimoire and read I think it's I
think it's a mix right like Aramis is a
character I believe that we summoned
from from the history of the game and it
also depends on you know how are our
lore which is largely looking into his
and and how how the the lore the
narrator's contained therein sometimes
reliables sometimes how that relates to
what we're doing we do have we do have a
plan and vision for from where we are
trying to take this story and you know
we may find the lore super valuable in
some respects and it's
the zag because I narrators maybe aren't
always reliable as we think they're with
the destiny content vault becoming a
thing and retiring a portion of the
current destiny content there's gonna be
people that will say that they feel like
they've lost money or wasted money than
they spent on content that go that they
can play utilization and the reason
behind it it obviously makes sense if
you can't you know update and patch your
game rule in it you know in a timely
manner what do you say to the people
that feel like they will have wasted
money on content they can't access if it
can access it I think it's I think it's
totally what we're trying to do is make
sure that we can continue to grow
destiny to in the direction that we want
to grow it and we want to give people
plenty of notification you know or more
so maybe in the future than this dear
with what is gonna with what is gonna go
away and the other thing is is we want
to we're setting this up in such a way
that the content is gonna go free and
it's life cycle before it goes away and
so it's not like we want to avoid
situations or someone pays for something
that's you giving it away for free you
can't complain some of the harsh reality
here is you know content that we're
pulling out of the game this year
vaulting well it's some content that's
not it's not some of its lesser play
some of its luster or cluster realized
you know I don't think a lot of people
are way through these days even though I
think the red water school it totally
represents a chunk of a chunk of effort
from our team a chunk of effort from our
players and certainly a period in in
Destiny's history you know we have to we
have to remember the less I might even
touch the red war yeah that's like basis
being added I'm just gonna ask some
direct ones it is a brand new subclass
so there will be four per class correct
a brand-new subclass for per class what
do you everybody so you have our voice
over stages
yeah yeah for some classes break into
jail here a little bit oh the these
subclasses will be different than how
the current subclasses are selected they
will not be locked diamonds they are
going to be a brand new a brand new
model that allows for much more player
choice like diamonds all right well you
know that sounds like right away this
sounds like they're gonna be changing
all of that you want to start with this
one idea as they add new stuffs gonna
change those into the current three
subclasses see how this will go to make
those do the reddit to the other ones
players have much more flexibility
somebody might even just replay it on me
too well probably makes it some stuff
will probably go away we're taking that
really seriously I love this game is
there any concern around homogeneous a
ssin between subclasses or balancing now
that you're gonna have four with
something you know with with options
underneath that yeah I think imagination
is just for me kind of an ongoing
concern but it's really hard to to make
something that competes with you know
turn into a which is what a bunch of our
modal supers are and so we've got to
figure out what's the excuse me what's
the right balance for them for those
things you know I think that in I'll
kind of just talk out of church here for
a second I think that the relationship
between the supers in nature destiny one
which was maybe a little bit more
interesting than what we have today or
today the classes do kind of have
similar versions of the same supers
and I think there's an opportunity for
us let's go that's all bit more than
they are saying but you know that's the
thing we again take really seriously you
know people people might identify as you
know like I am only a spectral blades
hunter rude a number of different
questions were I've been brought up
around sudden setting and the plans how
that's gonna be implemented so I'll just
hit you with a couple of those will
there be a completely new set of weapons
in the loop pool after each sunset or
will we be collecting our better Devils
version three look it's gonna be it's
gonna be a mix we're gonna keep updating
that pool I think we the team's actively
developing a bunch of new traits or
perks and so I hope that well I hope
that we do I think we can do better than
it's the same better WI than the exact
same roles like go and get it like that
seems that seems I'm his Sun setting
being implemented as a way to force
players to shake up the meta within both
PvE and PvP it's not being implemented
to force players to do and it has a
knock-on effect you know as as max power
level goes up certain weapons you know
will fall by the wayside and at least in
a high-level competitive active good
properties even though I also know that
some distance for our players we're you
know wielding a gun and desam different
than wielding a a for something in an
MMO being the staff is basically just
glorified stats and our weapons team you
know curates each legendary you know
just very bespoke Lee so it's easy to
find a gun I hope it's easy to find a
gun that you fall in love with and that
you love this boring the idea of that
that going away you know or that that
not being viable 12% of activities I
guess is is it's hard for people to
reconcile Sorel coming back oh yes Lupo
going into Lupo
but I do that people miss it I think
they need to bring it back it's a good
question do we have an expectation on
yes or no and timing especially with
cross play in the future for dedicated
servers for PvP yes concern about
staying with the same name just saying
we we see you don't ever any plans for
whisper or outbreak type missions in the
future you know Suchet I think everybody
can it can be okay with that and kind of
read into it a little bit I'm sure
they're smart any plans for I'm gonna
ask a couple easy ones cuz I've been
hitting you with some tough stuff for
advanced for beards
yeah no that would that injured people
keep bringing up see this is about Bala
was able to say [ __ ] sorry to put on
my female characters but we're we're in
the process of redoing they can redo
that we miss engine any plans for like a
an auto dismantle on please please even
those except for maybe one or two do
what the Lord's work please a chance to
just have those get filtered right into
the the butter churner as soon as you
pick them up I think hey when am I gonna
start using greens and blues again and
you know I think that's a that's an
interesting question because right now
we have a bunch of the colors that in
fact aren't used and so you know that's
my version of that question
don't worry that the thing I'm talking
about is not happening this fall but
that is that's a that's a real design
course
which is you know why do we have these
other colors
what's the reasoning behind some of the
the blanket weapon nerfs we have
outliers high-impact fusions 150 rpm now
one or two individuals their reasoning
that that's the way that that's gonna
taking it oh man it's right
Lupo hit me historically I'll look at
hands touched because the technology so
so he's like damn like then I was like
yet Tom I'm specifically what's the
team's design philosophy behind what
their current long-term PvP pursuit is
specifically VP and I will guess I would
say both seasoning rivals and the next
expansion a big question is a very big
question how to get a part of it Lou
Boyle and Nick perfect
how much longer do I have you for
no more I really got happy to go there
go some days um I had I tried to hit as
many as I could but thank you very much
for your time Lukas ensued which I mean
I don't think anybody what was on his
back the bathroom Luke thank you very
much for your time I appreciate you see
how to book he knew the bathroom was
full of us for full gays II you go to
bathroom as you Dale I'm okay as good
interviewing skills right there y'all
there you go chap of Destiny to
and I think I probably ran him further
past the time that I originally had for
him so hopefully that was good I tried
to ask as many as many questions from
this massive list that you guys brought
forward hopefully if any other channels
are restreaming this now you did you did
right by me hold this phone to answer
your questions he's got hopes
expectations for the future there's a
lot that came out of that a lot of
people in chat we're talking about
cheating very specific I completely
ignored that question because there's no
good answer from Luke they've talked
about it a bunch of times doing
everything they can just like respect
the most you could tell he was really he
was trying to be candid with his answers
but it was awful trying to be and
genuine with his answers because it
wasn't like a bunch of care responding
as to what he had to say a lot of just
leaky even when three came up he thought
about it for a second it was like we
don't want to make it as they turn their
stream to entertain you to watch me I
had them in the boss grave I think after
last season like questions like that had
to be there you go that's what that's
why I Luke did and I pull the plug
earlier because he said he Adam longer
than a few nights there were a lot of
questions that were asked through a
number of different methods a lot of
yeah we could tell them about the middle
that's true right he's like you know
what it was all kept looking off camera
[Music]
is it look like Luke was about to start
sweating Russia it was
he literally feels like a fraud it was
like I'm strong boiling and water he
started a beer with neighbor and he
started turning it up towards the
drunken ninja hey what was one of the
question what was it one of the
questions he gave him the change Rufus
what was what was that last question so
that's it that's a big question for that
man is about to have entire articles
made over that go cat daddy that's fast
he was looking at PR to save him like
your PR get me out of it later he was
shot at though that's a fact
might be submitted yo man he was it's
like when you get it jumped how you
waited for some political like look what
his face like I just like how he
increased the intensity of those
questions over times didn't dodge the
ones where he'd like PvP he dodged but
he said like how they tick rate system
you know I don't know nothing about all
that I don't expect you to know cuz he's
just a game director he don't know about
the back into the game like that know
what's funny it was just like how savage
he was that much time he was asking as
many questions he could get oh yeah yeah
bro
yeah that's crazy whole bunch of
trailers there was a information on like
a 12 almost like a patch notes right
build a viable future
oh this is versus TLDR that was that was
pretty funny Michael that's greatly like
me he gonna go through this this radish
so there it is
you never say we all light and then what
you call it which create 2021 so we go
through Mises September Cadence's right
yeah it most likely mm-hmm cuz be all
yeah this is sometimes be online I'm not
gonna lie I want that which Queen now
like I'm all because I love this a
between things that they always be
putting in mmm-hmm at least we know now
though Thomas Frank [ __ ] he was like
Lord why have you forsaken you know
daddy quarter service right my soul yeah
no you know it was funny
he asked about secret let's like well
they wouldn't be too secret if they were
if we told them it was effect over all
scream everybody final thoughts on this
thing man
now we got the Luke you know expose with
loco Lupo I'm saying like we feel him
scream birthday boy hit a home run and
I've been taking there for a while now
so yours alone
now the he when he was strongest on it
don't scream was trying I was I don't
know I mean you would I would fight you
and I you it was strong inside our
discord yeah well y'all probably had
that conversation at a disc or more but
I gave it to that's where price go be
fired yes it is no Freddy continues to
open but not just like the no destiny
three thing which you know the thing
about it is is you really they kind of
announced today like not just destiny
three bit like destiny three four and
five you know in a Serie in a certain
way it was really bright but you'll
certainly get as much out of it mmm-hmm
but also like the what's the expansion
that the way
what's the name of it exactly the witch
queen witch queen yeah I feel like I was
kind of that sort of is what I'm
thinking - like that was what I was
thinking you've been alluding that she's
missing yeah I thought Sabbath une needs
to be a player here and I'm just gonna
say it
other sob I think it's her think it's
her ah Daisy Doo we approve this I don't
know I mean it's hard to it's hard to
argue against that ego and I mean it's
to get dearie you've seen the battles
that I've had with a lord zero yes
arguing this yeah so it's hard to argue
against everything that they're putting
out and they're showing forward I mean
they put a lot of stuff out there yeah
one thing has to stick you know it could
have been a variety of things and this
is the way that they're going with right
so scream overall like USA overall I I
loved it I think I thought it hit a home
run I think it's gonna be a exciting
enough summer moving into a very
exciting fall and like a much more but
sees the power cap is 1062 Slayer
friendly like a year or so okay so post
dreamscreen last country like everybody
this is like how are you feeling about
the future of destiny like how are you
are you real strong you're super
positive are you skeptical or really I'm
skeptical and I think I'm pretty
positive I think it's gonna I really
think it's just gonna like I said it's
gonna be a exciting summer which moves
into like a mall is gonna be I think
really really big and then I think after
that just the fact that they laid out a
roadmap like they did today
mm-hmm I think there's a lot for you
know I I'm always more invested if I
know a company is more invested and they
sometimes if they're not they'll keep
you on the fence you know they don't
tell you exactly what they're doing but
they told us a lot of what they're
planning on doing today so that means
that they're putting a you know they're
putting a lot down on this okay so I
think he said like they're gonna double
down on what works I like the idea of
bringing back old stuff the way I think
that'll work too he's like I think
you'll sort of get almost like we have a
rotating set of stuff that we do every
week and sometimes there's like
Nightmare hunts for example right like
there's six Nightmare hunts but we only
get three we can do every week right so
what if on like a monthly or you know
seasonal thing we get something that
returns back and if it's people really
loved it it stays for a while they
siphon something out but nothing is ever
there so long as it's not popular
anymore
so whatever is popular will be in as far
as like rate or something along those
lines pretty nice life and out stuff
that was maybe brought in later it's
more current that isn't nearly as
popular got you Dizz you have not played
destiny in a while you came back you
okay you're felwinter's lie day before
god sure did for your suggestion I sure
did so where you at you've been in and
out with destiny how are you let me let
me kind of hit on a kind of what was
alluded to with the hole on the roadmap
and everything here's what it actually
reminds me of is remember when destiny
before the release of the first testing
they did this they put out a roadmap
they said hey we're gonna do this in
between each of these major expansions
we're gonna have little DLCs here and
there and they did that for what half a
year mm-hm
it all changed right and when we never
saw a roadmap kind of like that again
seeing that roadmap back up there and
also kind of recognize these seasons are
exactly what they wanted those like the
dark below and uh was it the House of
wolves yeah it kind of like fills them
with those gaps you know what they
wanted to do with that in the back of my
mind I'm thinking Activision would have
been kicking and screaming if they saw
something like you
this grenade launcher they give you in
the season passes oh my god crazy
it it it shoots a blight on the floor
I'm about to start playing it amazing we
go we gonna school but uh was gonna say
so now finish Daisy that I got I gotta
move along I gotta get Deborah Forte
yeah so from what I see it has enough
that I'm actually interested in playing
again it brings you back in if they can
continue and take the steps that they
need you to continue to move forward
playing I think that they're taking
these steps now that you know the reins
are free mm-hmm I think that the future
can only go up as long as they don't
manage it I'll free what singular thing
most excited you'd is being able to do
some of the old stuff in the back of my
mind even though they doing some of the
old stuff I'm still sitting here hoping
that hey you like this gun back then
here's a way that you can earn that gun
back and I'm like give me my super so
bad I thought you came out super self
red of def estudio de bajo all feeling
how pumped are you where you at with
this thing man all the news happy with
all the right story beats ago the law
stuff there everything's done add up
it's time that blue sends like I see the
X and a tie up so now I can predict with
the story my girl the content is solid
false glasses coming back which is the
goat hopeful the Ben's return as well
all the guns and all the glory
yeah it's looking good
I said they needed to need this seasonal
ever needed me good the DLC needed to
hit because of previous seasons when hit
the mark
and they brought everyone back and they
did exactly what they needed to do this
was what they needed what singular thing
got you be most excited out of
everything in this reveal it's that's
difficult a big one it's going to be the
deep so crypt and the
ellaby the deep snow cryptid the Elsi
break his story that is really
intriguing no doubt no doubt
Forte my brother what's up what's up man
we've been doing this thing a long time
how we feeling about this whole thing so
I'm glad I came into this with my temper
expectations because the one thing that
I cared about the most was just knowing
where we were going where what was what
was next for us are we are we gonna
continue down the same road that we
always been continuing our are we gonna
start making genuine changes a lot of
that stuff is still up in the air
because they're still working on some
stuff on the back end which is fine but
I love the direction of saying like this
is what our timeline is now they're
starting to give us that timeline over
the course of years versus just the next
three to four months I love I love that
and the fact that we argue I get bought
a glass crap just because I love things
lot more but I'm not gonna lie bro when
I saw it I was like oh dude it's like go
back to that go back we get any exacts
for more we mix it no they're gonna
remix it they're not gonna bring it back
because even when they did they did
angels destiny trips there is off yeah
but but it's just more of the fact that
I love this franchise and they they find
a way to bring you back in even when you
go through your worst season they come
out and they speak to the community the
way the community wants to be spoken to
not just pay lip service to but actually
listening to what they want to be done
and I don't expect things to be
completely different in season 11
because I know 11 to season 10 is oh
it's season 12 be ultimately the
differences in changes from season 11 I
mean for a season 10 so I'm willing to
wait on that but knowing that there is a
long term grind in place to let you know
that we're gonna respect your grind
going forward and we're gonna let you
know when stuff is gonna be taken away
from you way
earlier in the vanston ever percent it
didn't affect that consoles probably my
most successful at six so I don't have
to do with the Lord's work Lord's work
the only thing Lupo could've did was ask
him are we gonna have a fov slide yeah
I've got about the LOB slider but dude
if I can just like with sixty frames
that's all I care about
and that will that's enough right there
to keep me going with destiny because
that there's point man destiny is more
of it's more of its way of life honestly
when it comes to gaming for a lot of us
and we just loved this game so much
other games still matter too but when
you don't got nothing to play just
always they're free and they prove that
over the next four years death still be
home to the people that actually love it
to my last question Forte what so it's a
singular thing
what's the singular thing if you have to
rape the singular thing that excited
most excited to just getting off getting
off PC and go back to console literally
literally that dad is literally the
singular thing because all the content
in the world is great but if I can't
play with the people I want to play it
with on the consistent basis it's for
naught and that's why I'm happy about
console getting what they're getting
addict by destiny brother who's gone
away it's going away it's been not happy
lately been very casual how are we
feeling about all these announcements
it's all cute and I see them do
something with it like I gave me hope
for the brand but it's just like look
for every one time they gave me hope
they disappointed me four more times
like it's just like because they have a
habit of committing and the rescinding
like all the time like every time they
do some more we like the shotgun to you
know what we messed up let's let's grab
those those chips and bring them back a
little bit I like what they're doing
with the vault thing because I feel like
that's a good middle ground to not take
away take away Consett but
still update the game mm-hmm because how
do you know they implement that it's
likely you think they're gonna duel or
wise or is it gonna be you think they do
like no it's like a classic greatest
it's it's it's it's it's gonna be a
great thing okay it's gonna be one of
those things where it's like look we
might not have much for you in terms of
seating then there's another thing I I
fear what they are they gonna start
using that to to sell future seasons and
stuff oh you know November the fourth
the vote of glass is coming back and
then that's like the highlight of that
season
is selling us old [ __ ] from a previous
game so you don't want the whole stuff
to come back at all I wanted to come
back but I don't want I don't want it to
be the highlight of everything they do
because now like no note that think
about from this point they had on they
went from not from selling us old
constant like Oh actual structures like
the moon so now they could sell us out
of bits like oh you know this season we
got the vote of glass for you next
season we're gonna pop you with the fall
what the aurochs is red what you know is
cool and all it is like but it's just
like where do we end mmm so you're not
convinced my glass course is you know I
mean I got my life for you but you're
not convinced about enough new content
and that old content it's something I'm
not convinced they won't do it it's just
like I have to go off what they've shown
me and what they've shown me is they
love selling us old content but there's
always certain things they couldn't do
right because it was in destiny one it's
like you can't redo vault of glass
because that events over you can't redo
the rate because it no longer exists but
now you put this Twilight Zone apart it
does see where you could easily sell us
old [ __ ] again right
what you're opposed to it's not that I'm
opposed to I just don't want to taking
away from what new contact could be okay
okay like you know I like the new planet
I like going
two new things but if you think about it
since the Dreaming city like that's
really all that we've really seen new
out of all destiny to write like in
terms of like locations right until you
know III what your rope or whatever
yeah Europe I like what they're doing
with the game you know I'm in the first
mission right now it's I love destiny
and you know I don't even mind them
reselling us oh [ __ ] it's just that
can't be what they market anything
around because to me oh [ __ ]
like especially raised you know raised
and stuff you know that can't be the
lead marketing thing you use it's like
let's take for example last season in
their defense they didn't use it good
yeah well I'm just saying I'm just
talking about for what we've seen right
what we've seen so far at least well for
Europa it's new what but I see what
you're saying like at least happen yet
right but at least I have let's see that
a season an annual pass doesn't set off
like yo falls back as the lead point so
this is like okay a prime example you
really love this last season but I was
no no no no I'm talking I'm talking
about trials of Osiris oh you loved that
because I should think what I'm saying
then the events you look well that is
something that you love yes what yes I
liked it from destiny one but I was
never in love with it from destiny war
so meat to me that was selling a season
based off old content they're like
dishes brain back trials but nobody
liked it but you get what I'm saying
right like you know I don't mind them
doing that it's just it can't be the
primary focus for [ __ ] right and you
know I I have a lot of faith because I
was more interested in how he worded
stuff than how the trailers like the the
the the Q&A afterwards was more
interesting to me than yes then whatever
PR put together well yeah because PR I
always lock it out the park so we got
that part so I yeah and you know the
thing that they're doing really a lot
better job
explaining situation explaining lore in
a game like you know it used to be they
did they didn't do the greatest job at
it and you know meet you've had that
conversation before because we thought
the season thing was going to be the new
thing right but it looks like you know
they backed up on that just a little bit
where you're gonna have one big
expansion every year and then you have
seasons to build up to the next
expansion that's how I want it to be I
don't mind paying the money as long as
the content is good enough yeah but at
the same time the build-up has to have
equality as well and the problem has
been to build up outside of a few story
cool story beats would say 14 and a
couple other things the majority of it
has been lackluster and like Lubow is
saying these weak public event kind of
things where you don't feel invested
very light you know I'm saying where a
lot of the community has say hey I'm not
gonna really rock let's be real like I
took off three weeks a lot you were
really playing you know sales I didn't
play the whole season the only season
that I didn't get a jury in my pale I'll
jump in real quick but I was like the
jury of my pay is still out on the
Annual Pass format because they still
have not proven that they can give
substantial concert in their defense
it's hard to keep giving content content
like some September thing right so but
at the same time you know the majority
of the base is not satisfied with the
$10 drop so far I would say I guess I've
always been different with that and like
as long as like I want more the story to
be like Saint though all every season
like I know they did they Center it or
out something in the entire season is
building that something up into the next
season and you know I'll you know I love
what they did with the the sake 40 but I
still think they messed up there I think
saint himself got revived too soon and
because he got revived too soon because
it felt like for like two months we had
nothing to do because they built that up
way too fast it was like they had a
couple good weeks and the Saint was out
it was like what are we doing we will do
for Less seasons which is the challenge
of doing this type of content because
you you literally have to have every
something popping every along the way
every
part of the roadmap but I get it I get
let me just move out are we going along
but I want to ask you what was the
singular most exciting thing that you
saw everything this year that's again I
know I'm gonna sound hypocritical oh
don't you go say to vault the glass
after all that no no no it's not that
I'm a big great person in the way
they're looking it looks like they're
going away from your traditional one
rate a year I mean multiple you know
they did even though that we clown on
the rail is they were still there if I
wanted a placement they were still there
like I've went like six seven months
without a raid in it's it's definitely
affecting me well III I do enjoy the
fact that they're Britt there they had
that and he said about the new husband I
know you talk about the new ray I do
rate that not that nine doesn't know you
just about a new rate in general I'm
talking about the fact that they had
issues with being able to develop new
ray content new seasonal stuff I like
the dungeons but it doesn't replace a
ray like a six-man raid it doesn't
replace and that's literally the only
reason I play destiny right it's to is
to grind to the raid so I do you know at
the same time that I don't want them
reselling stuff I do like that they're
giving you that option if it comes up I
just don't want them to revolve
everything around it I don't want them
because they know motor glass is so
important they think they literally know
they could sell that to you and just
that for an entire season and build
everything around that one event look at
that so what's the answer to the
question the fact that they do it
classic rains coming back is the f no
like yet that is definitely the the
biggest thing I know maybe it's a sixty
frame thing because I'm really filling
that wine but the the fact that you know
I might be able to see like the fallen
king again in destiny to with up good a
lot of people don't keep forgetting like
we have different mechanics than we did
in destiny way so I really like to see
so there's like the reality is you're
torn because you know what you want that
content back but you know what there's a
blast up as a singular sake selling
point of that content and that that's
what I've always said I don't mind them
bringing old content Bank I do mind them
always revolving the entire game off Oh
Bronson
I respect like the moon shadow keeper
they literally revolve
around sure we got new strikes but we'll
they got like one new strike it's like
they revolved the entire DLC the entire
expansion around an old planet that we
went to back in like 2014 right like it
was the moon back
um look ya'll this was expectations as
low for me you need we just came off the
worst season and destiny in the history
of the franchise let's just call it what
it is he won couldn't think we would get
lower than curse of Osiris and Boyd we
get lower the crucible sorry it was a so
dad dad was definitely the worse
she's in a world you definitely see am i
my dumb ass is on here giving them $10
for this listen we crack a is like like
slow-mo said you don't say we gonna play
it see what it is and then if it's not
to our liking we out so I think that's
what the majority of us did I think it's
$10 it's too low I can't say too much I
wish they would get more to me when they
think about the $10 thing that needs to
be more about you know we need to war we
need this cuz I think they like to spend
the money they get with the season pass
into the season prize but I don't think
that's the way you do because if you do
it that way you're gonna damage your
brand you have to spend money with the
season pass to correctly build the build
up right to make more money down the
road from CA about that the issue is
like we've always said is the actual
infrastructure in the bandwidth they
don't have hi moon they don't have my
carrots anymore it's not excuses it's
just the reality so now this is all them
and expected them to release out of
cadence that you know we expect like
shadow keep levels and it's just not
feasible unless they acquire someone you
know I'm saying so look at the other
days this low expectations this was a
home run as far as I'm concerned yes as
far as all the information presented
even to be honest and I got to give deaf
this I told deaf to chill on season
what's the next one see this one we
started today is Season eleven well see
ya I told Jeff to calm down or seasonal
that like I I told him we're getting a
dungeon right now like that's a big deal
I know it's not a raid to
it's like Dungeons a big deal you know
saying so that's that's them yes it's a
homerun listen to what I'm saying
slow-mo you know it kind of because I
have to go to work today for four hours
so we can do that strain Thursday and
I'm like this but I don't think I'm even
high enough level to do these on run
based on every bit of the road map that
was presented you know I'm saying we got
clarity on next-gen right we got clarity
on cross play we got clarity on whether
this thing is gonna be a sequel or not I
still have my questions there but we got
clarity like the future each year we got
okay you're getting this this is the
season of The Scarlet Witch or whatever
this is the season it or whatever and
it's very clear that that's a September
joint going forward it kind of surprised
me that they opened up with that right
that that to me is a big deal I'm not
gonna understand it he said as a ground
and making the front you better stop
anyway moving along so that was the
first thing um I think overall I love
the UM the the story beats how they look
like they've gotta be doing it with the
season pass with the joint with homegirl
the strange I thought that was dull
overall listen man they'd laugh like
yeah there was some things I have my I
still have questions on it wasn't like
oh my god it's all perfect but it's all
run for the flow of the franchise and
now we just got to see it's a home run
as far as how it to present it and what
they're gonna do
like you said slow the key now is do
they execute everything single thing in
a good manner because on paper
everything sounded fire everything
something it's okay to mess up but
they've been consistently messing up
like it's like you have a hiccup every
now and then people your fan base ain't
gonna really do much but when you have
no work yeah here's the thing this is
difference between that's why I say it's
a home run this is between Destiny's
other MMOs whether it be anthems
you know division or whatever you're in
the dark not knowing what they're doing
you don't know that's what I say like
that's the difference like that the
destiny could mean Wilson a
with you if you tell them what's really
going on like hey we can't afford to do
this but that's why they're allowed that
clarity the the crackhead miss we go
back to the drug because at least the
drug dealer honest with what he doing
yo said that dads are you know what is
dig is the season thing uh like the
whole season like yeah they say they say
yeah I have a feeling during this whole
season they're gonna blow up these
planets because on the directory right
now yeah one of those ships is over IO
and I was not on that screen and yeah I
heard somebody I think somebody think
Josh was in the chat earlier saying it
somebody saw the new director I think
somebody said cactus agent yeah yeah
yeah director up in it and if you look
at the directory right now with the
updated directory of right now yeah the
ship is over I own I was not on that I
was not on that directory so I think
throughout the next couple months
these these locations gonna get blown up
now here's the day I'm to me the
singular most thing and it's it's
important is the cross play and in the
thing that I mean not to cross scuse me
SD is the 64 games oh wait we're forte
on that the 60 frames the cross play now
I don't know how I feel about it just at
first just being limited one play have
we ever had seasonal currency I don't
know um I don't know if it's limited to
platform I'm gonna be y'all know how I
feel about that the Xbox guys are sticky
with the Xbox as a PlayStation guys and
I guess stadia still body so cuz with a
stick it with who they buy by the time
it's for this year by the time boy hits
gonna be too late for stadia tell me he
mentioned it it would loophole stuck
them tell me how this sword anyway like
I was saying that thing is gonna come
down to the execution of that with the
crossbow the 60 frames is huge
that's huge bro that that that gets
people late that's single Hanley just so
Xbox series axes and psy people it is it
is such a huge deal because did knock
against Xbox and PlayStation was that
they would never do it because go on
31st at a dirty friends diver
the 60 frames guy it's happening that's
a that's a big deal
we cannot understate that so that's what
I got and we just gonna see you man but
tell me what you saw that we gotta get
out of it the sort they have us they
have a skin on here it looks like the
Buster blader Oh like ya ask ya ask
Forte it's it's on the season pass -
that's great it's but it's madhyam there
man it's a boy it's a it's a it's a
voice or two it's it's 88 the emoji said
buns you did a bad job Acts continue to
extreme it's done far better stuff
Philip
there's things that's weird on here like
you know how they always have those
engrams there's different unique engrams
every season they have an umbrella annum
brutal eating cream I can't oh no that's
the legendary and grab that who
basically drops any legendary item it's
like it's like the regular Engram but it
could drop anything so how do you get
those a body oh it was late man another
good we have to do more of these because
we do talk about destiny too much not
the whole problem for father Hoppe
concern I had low expectations I did not
expect to be hitting oh it was great it
was a great thing I just need to see
execute yeah of course I'm just talking
about what was presented how it was
presented that's all I'm talking of
course they got execute we'd know about
that but happy birthday to my bro
Wilhelm scream got his wish
got his D to forever he's living on a
cloud down right now you know and of
course the Lord's will be back on
Thursday for that PlayStation stream
everybody's do a little sign out selling
where you at all that good stuff start
with scream the birthday boy tell me
what your channel is tell them where
they can find you all that good stuff
Wilhelm scream Wilhelm with a 1 w IL h e
1m scream on YouTube
mm-hmm typing that with destiny if you
really have a hard time follow me and at
Wilhelm underscore scream on Twitter you
already know this claim and of course
that was already out of here I don't
have single or Twitter gaming for take
my brother bout to get into his
experiences
we're gonna make it quick way to people
find you yo man yeah man gave me Forte
on YouTube you twitter man that's the
best places I've got some destiny stuff
that's gonna be coming up on the shadows
so if y'all want to take that
conversation on the main channel
subscribe to channel man it's gonna be a
good time this season or eNOS slow-mo
said he coming out his destiny video
right now for us he's called the truth
about destiny crackheads like he already
made that death video didn't he say he
doing just you just got to make sure I
can read the thumb though leave my bed
alone anyway gonna have some color in
that stuff savy dizzy low as a gay bird
dot debt up in the building we're gonna
find people finds what you got going on
sir you are still muted so hopefully
you're back yeah I'm unit 81 across the
board of course over at Lords of gaming
that met where we got the hottest whoa
[Music]
like I said I'm busy anyone across the
board Xbox Twitter PlayStation Nintendo
unless you want the social security now
a big money like oh wow though Yuri does
salute salute Lord any videos coming up
anything we should be looking out for
sir
mmm not not really I'm gonna I have a
video on standby I'm probably gonna
release tomorrow it's just my you know
predictions of what's gonna happen in
Thursday show so definitely look out for
that over on the gaming attic show
channel and uh you know what would
definitely you want to catch this
Thursday I don't know if Kings gonna be
there as king so you know you know how
that's going alright like you only does
he - I just watch his Twitter you
already get the pre hype for what hi he
coming yo this this new armor look crazy
you get me mad cuz I want to play oh
look look to the Chairman y'all was
let's see some new subscribers in there
we're gonna get this thing fixed out you
know horns you can you trumpets got a
whole lot of things you join the realm
salute to y'all two hours Yacht rock
with us that's crazy for some destiny I
thought this game was dead hello
anyway everybody enjoy today we'll see
you guys Thursday man and we